[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue à la paris cei
leurs week le forum européen de
l'économie numérique pour un nouveau
numéro du 7 8 et co consacrée à un enjeu
phare du 21e siècle
la cyber sécurité autrement dit la
protection des données numériques
c'est parti pour les titres de ce
magazine c'est le forum européen de
l'économie numérique la première édition
de la paris seiver week s'est tenue le 5
et 6 juin à paris associé à l'événement
saint quentin en yvelines a reçu une
délégation internationale
objectif présenter le secteur de la
cyber sécurité sur le territoire
un partenariat entre airbus
cybersécurité et cilly comme le groupe
leader européen du secteur et la pme
installée à guyancourt travaillent
ensemble sur une plateforme commune
un simulateur de cyberattaques pour
s'entraîner à la cyber sécurité avant de
parler de la paris seiver week retour
sur le colloque de génération
entreprises entrepreneurs associés
organisée par cette association de
parlementaires jeudi 6 juin cet
événement a permis d'aborder la guerre
économique et la place de la france dans
ce conflit des échanges sur la cyber
sécurité et la souveraineté économique
regardez la guerre économique et
commerciale entre la chine et les
etats-unis les présidentes donald trump
exige hinting s'affrontent à coups de
droits de douane et de sanctions quid de
la france et de l'union européenne dans
ce conflit c'est le thème du colloque
organisé par l'association génération
entreprise présidée par olivier dassault
et jean michel fourgous avec la question
du patriotisme économique
on a souvent assimilé le patriotisme
économique ou protectionnisme c'est le
pas du tout la même chose
protectionnisme c'est le repli complet
sur soi c'est la mythologie de
l'autosuffisance du patriotisme
économique ce n'est jamais que la
défense et la promotion de nos intérêts
économiques particuliers industriels
dans le respect du principe de
réciprocité est ce qui fait d'ailleurs
part jean michel fourgous dans le bassin
de saint quentin en yvelines participe
justement de la promotion de ce
patriotisme économique auquel je suis si
attaché airbus thalès ou encore safran
plusieurs leaders industriels installés
sur saint quentin en yvelines des géants
français et européens mais insuffisant
selon bernard carayon je crois qu'il
manque encore
d'une vraie politique industrielle en
europe et cette politique industrielle
aujourd'hui est entravée par la
politique de la concurrence qui
empêchent nos grandes autres de se
constituer en mastodonte pour affronter
justement les mastodontes américains
indiens ou chinois
autre sujet abordé la cybersécurité avec
un engagement particulier de saint
quentin en yvelines pour soutenir la
formation dans ce domaine
les formations en tout cas si la
sécurité nous on mélange les très belles
boîtes les plus belles boîtes françaises
sur la cybersécurité sur le numérique
avec des jeunes et des moins jeunes et
des écoles qui veulent réussir donc
voilà c'est ce ce mariage subtil qui
fera la pertinence certainement de la
réussite de la france qui se protégera
dans cette révolution
la cyber sécurité un enjeu important
dans un contexte de guerre économique
d'après les prévisions le nombre de
cyberattaques devrait augmenter de 500 %
d'ici à 2020
[Musique]
e
l'appareil seiver week ces deux jours de
conférences sur les enjeux du numérique
un forum européen rassemblant des
acteurs et des experts du secteur pour
échanger sur les questions de la cyber
sécurité
partenaire de l'événement saint quentin
en yvelines a accueilli une délégation
internationale
un reportage sur des images de michael
ennemis devront assurer la sécurité de
la transformation numérique avec le
développement du digital la
cybersécurité devient un enjeu important
l'appareil sidekick forum européen de
l'économie numérique a permis d'informer
d'échanger de faire de la pédagogie sur
cette activité
nous pensons que si nous voulons
transformer
la société est intégré l'impact
numérique il faut absolument que ce soit
avec la confiance des utilisateurs à la
confiance là que la cybersécurité kivu
la porte
en parallèle la délégation officielle de
cet événement s'est rendu au ski cube
présents notamment des représentants de
pays européens comme l'estonie ou la
finlande des échanges informels sur
leurs expériences concept le secteur
public créé les concepts la manière dont
la cyber sécurité nationale devrait
ressembler et après nous incluons et
nous demandons secteur privé de fournir
les services et les produits
la politique va être de plus en plus
importante je dois dire cela et je suis
très heureux par exemple quand je lis la
nouvelle stratégie cyber de la france et
de voir le nombre d'hommes politiques se
pencher sur cette question c'est quelque
chose que nous devons apprendre dans les
autres pays européens dès maintenant
avec une trentaine d'entreprises
engagées dans la cybersécurité
saint-quentin-en-yvelines souhaite
développer un campus dans ce domaine en
collaboration notamment avec
l'université versailles saint quentin
déformation de la recherche et d'autres
activités proposées une composante
centre d'entraînement pour pouvoir parer
aux différentes attaques
et puis bien sûr comme on nous l'avons
essayée à skis cube une composante
start-up incubateur pour développer les
entreprises de demain en matière de
cybersécurité à saint quentin en
yvelines
ce projet est en cours d'élaboration
objectif pour 2022 regrouper deux mille
étudiants spécialisés en cyber sécurité
c'est une collaboration lancé depuis le
début de l'année 2019 d'un côté airbus
cybersécurité leader européen de son
secteur 30 % de croissance en 2018
de l'autre la pme silicone spécialiste
du conseil stratégique en haïti 10%
croissance en 2018
implantée à guyancourt ils ont noué un
partenariat sur la formation autour de
la cybersécurité à partir d'une
plateforme de simulation de
cyber-attaque
nous avons rencontré jean de cornulier
et arthur bataille sur le site d'airbus
à elancourt c'est une illustration de
l'open innovation dans le secteur de la
cybersécurité sur saint quentin en
yvelines
le groupe airbus collabore avec l'apn
silicone objectif accélérer l'innovation
et nous sommes avec arthur bataille
directeur associé de silicone fait et
j'en de cornulier producteur manager
chez airbus cybersécurité pour
travailler notamment sur la cyber rush
que nous avons devant nous alors d'abord
je me tourne vers vous arthur bataille
pouvez vous nous dire quelques mots sur
silicon alors s'ils commettent une pme
française qui a été créée en 83 une
société de conseil spécialisée notamment
dans le domaine de la défense et de la
sécurité
on est une société qui collabore avec le
groupe eads depuis de nombreuses années
qui est devenue maintenant airbus des
français le space est la filiale cyber
security on est une société innovante et
d'ailleurs on a eu l'idée de former nos
collaborateurs de les accompagner dans
le fait de progresser dans le domaine de
la cybersécurité et les former sur la
notion de il indigné effectivement on
l'abordera parce que c'est là
l'entreprise que vous avez créé s'il a
tout à fait notamment qui collabore avec
airbus cybersécurité gens de cornulier
on voit la cyber orange devant nous donc
c'est une plateforme de simulation de
cyber-attaque pour former justement la
cybersécurité comment été conçu ce
dispositif cher du cyber sécurité voilà
donc c'est une plateforme on avait une
intégration qui sommes de multiples cas
d' usage et en particulier le cyber
entraînements donc c'est un outil
interne d'airbus une solution interne
airbus qui était développé ici à
elancourt par des équipes qui sont dans
nos locaux et qui permet en fait de
reproduire le système d'information
d'une entreprise ou d'une industrie pour
derrière jouer des scénarios des
scénarios réalistes d'activités incluant
éventuellement des cyberattaques dont on
va pouvoir consulter toute une chaîne
est projeté de dents des stagiaires de
manière à ce qu'ils s'entraînent dans
des conditions très proches de ceux qui
rencontreront dans leurs missions au
quotidien dans l'entreprise et cet outil
donc c'est l'objet du partenariat que
vous avez tissé avec silicone or plus
précisément la société soeur ainsi la
tout à fait donc un projet de
collaboration
qu'est ce que ça fait pour cette société
sylla de collaborer avec l'un des
leaders de la cybersécurité rang
c'est exceptionnel d'autant plus qu'on
est une start up donc on est au tout
début de notre aventure avoir une
solution de e-learning sans avoir une
plate forme de cyber entraînements c'est
pour nous pas forcément pertinent on
avait besoin d'avoir quelque chose de
solide sur lequel s'appuyer et la
cyberhaine jeu nous permet d'avoir une
solution tout de suite fonctionnel avec
une capacité d'avoir des scénarios
d'attac et en plus le soutien des
experts d'airbus albert security qui
nous accompagne aussi dans la création
de ces scénarios pour les propres
besoins de sylla et de ses clients il
faut savoir que ce n'est pas exactement
la saveur orange que nous avons nous
avons une solution saas qui nous est
proposé on à l'intégralité des
fonctionnalités d'une vraie cyberhaine
jeu mais on n'a pas forcément toutes les
possibilités que l'on a avec une saveur
et physique qui aujourd'hui est un outil
on va dire très premium et nous nous
pouvons adresser aujourd'hui une
solution pour des pme des deux pays qui
ont ce désir de former leurs
collaborateurs
c'est un plus pour vous parce que vous
vous avez le dispositif physique et
comme vient de le préciser arthur
bataille
il développe plutôt un outil sur le
cloud donc pour autrement dit pour
internet directement sur le web pour
pour clarifier ça donc c'est
qu'effectivement on a commencé le
développement a qu'une plate forme
physique qu'on a commercialisé auprès de
nos clients
et aujourd'hui cette même plateforme on
la commercialise dans le cloud
donc il ya quelques nuances qui ont été
mentionnées sur le fondement de la plate
forme mais ça adresse les mêmes qu'à des
usages et donc on peut faire de
l'entraînement avec une plate forme
physique ou une plateforme dans le club
ensuite là où on a une collaboration
très intéressante et que
nous on apporte une plateforme technique
pas de faire cette simulation et slicom
a développé une plateforme de e learning
qui va donc de pousser des formations à
valeur ajoutée via un nouveau canal que
nous n'avions pas jusqu'à aujourd'hui et
qui permet de s'intégrer parfaitement
avec une scie blanche dans le club pour
jouer des exercices pratiques et nous ça
correspond parfaitement la philosophie
qu'on a chez airbus pour la formation la
formation cyber on préconise de
compléter la formation 20 30 pour cette
formation par des exercices pratiques
intenses en environnement réaliste
sursis bérange donc c'est là que cette
coupe la vérité était extrêmement
naturelle comment ça c'est créer cette
complémentarité parce que finalement un
grand groupe une start-up bon c'est de
plus en plus ça se fait de plus en plus
à travers le phénomène d'open innovation
mais comment ça c'est fait ce que c'est
vous qui êtes allés vers airbus
cybersécurité est ce que c'est le
contraire je pense que c'est une
histoire à deux quand on a commencé à
travailler dans le département cyber
security on était dans une notion plutôt
d'activité d'accompagnement de conseil
et on nous a présenté la solution sign
orange et les perspectives qui était
donnée d'un point de vue technologique
avec notamment toute la partie
virtualisation est mise en place dans le
cloud et on s'est dit mais pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas aller plus loin dans nous
notre offre de e-learning et se dire
qu'on avait réellement quelque chose
pour effectuer des problématiques et
répondre aux problématiques de teck
transfert parce que aussi je j'appuierai
ce que jean a pu expliquer aujourd'hui
un collaborateur qui se forme et qui se
sensibilise sur la cybersécurité c'est
très bien mais ça ne répond pas des
enjeux techniques est temps que les gens
n'ont pas les mains dans le cambouis à
proprement dit il y apparaît une réelle
valeur ajoutée en termes de formation
l'objectif pour vous c'est quoi en fait
pour votre société
l'objectif c'est d'adressé le plus grand
nombre de personnes et surtout de
réussir à créer un écosystème
en termes de connaissance et d'expertisé
en cybersécurité plus important en
france
déjà dans un premier temps on a une
perspective d'un peu plus de 1 8 million
de postes qui vont être ouverts en
cybersécurité d'ici 2022 et je pense que
même pour la société de conseil silicum
que je représente avoir des gens
compétents capables d'interagir avec nos
clients et de répondre à leurs enjeux en
termes de sécurité au sens large c'est
fondamental je suppose que vous c'est
plus une valeur ajoutée le quelque chose
en plus pour airbus cybersécurité un
outil en plus pour booster la croissance
exactement mais survient la génèse comme
cela a été mentionné il ya une pénurie
de ressources dans ce secteur et on
également dans un contexte avec des
cyber attaques qui sont plus en plus
fréquentes et dont certaines sont
certainement connu maintenant du grand
public ce qui est important derrière
c'est à dire comment on peut accompagner
les organisations nos clients mais du
maire général lors l'ensemble de la
filière pour se structurer et permettre
de répondre à un besoin croissant en
termes d' expertise cyber on permette à
toutes les activités que ce soit aussi
bien un service public qu'une industrie
ou une entreprise de continuer son
activité régulière ce qui fait sa
mission
arthur bataille genre d'accord du liem
merci beaucoup pour cet entretien et on
l'a bien compris donc cet open
innovation entre airbus cybersécurité et
silicone contribue notamment à mettre en
avant le fait que la cyber sécurité est
un enjeu important du 21e siècle c'est
la fin de ce numéro merci de nous avoir
suivi on se retrouve le mois prochain au
salon du bourget pour une émission
consacrée au secteur de l'aéronautique
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]